around the world many governments have
been propping up their economies with
stimulus packages
to tackle the devastating effects of the
covid19 pandemic
america alone has spent trillions of
dollars it could be about to spend
trillions more
negotiations will continue today on a
second round of stimulus money and
unemployment benefits from the federal
government
the long-term impact of these
unprecedented fiscal measures
remains to be seen you submitted your
questions about america's stimulus
to john fassman our washington
correspondent
and callum williams as senior economics
writer
here are their answers where does the
stimulus money come from
i mean fundamentally it comes from the
us government
going out into the markets and and
borrowing money so at the moment the u.s
government is taking in
much less in uh taxes than it wishes to
spend and
is spending and so basically it has to
go to investors and say
we would like to borrow some money off
you and we will pay you for that
privilege and fortunately the conditions
are such that
the us government is able to borrow
really really vast amounts
trillions of dollars and uh that's not
going to cost them
all all that much given um given how
given that interest rates are fairly low
calum given that the american economy is
in such a state why is it still so easy
for the government to borrow
i think broadly speaking the answer is
to do with the fact that there's
really high demand at the moment and has
been for a while for kind of
safe assets and really the safest asset
in the whole world
is us government debt will the funds
actually reach the people who need it
most
you'll remember when the first round of
federal unemployment
stimulus came out it took a while for
that money to reach people because state
unemployment systems
are so creaky that they had to
effectively redesign them
to take in this new stream of funds the
worry about
trump's executive order on ui now is
that with 300
coming from the federal government and
100 coming from the states it's another
new
pair of income streams which means the
states will need to configure their
systems
to get that money to people which means
it will take some time to actually get
the money to the people who need it most
but john i guess also it's the case
right that there are large
sort of chunks of people in the u.s who
maybe were not even
eligible for say the stimulus checks
which were paid out in april
and maybe even still haven't got their
unemployment benefits per cap perhaps
because they have an irregular
immigration status and
all that kind of thing yeah i think
that's true there is a risk that some
people who need the money may not be
able to get it at all and remember that
the amount of money
that trump made available through his
executive order is just 44 billion so
that will last maybe six weeks
so whether people will get their money
within six weeks is an open question
and then after that the money goes away
so i think we'll probably see another
sort of
pinch later this fall how does the
american economic stimulus compare to
other countries globally
i mean there are a few other countries
like britain japan
singapore which get quite close but
america
is pretty pretty certainly the most
generous of the whole world
and that's i think particularly
extraordinary given how
stingy the american welfare state
generally is and how deep the reluctance
is to give people money when they're out
of work
in the u.s for complicated historical
reasons
every time there's a recession there
have to be these
these very prolonged negotiations that
congress about exactly how the us
government is going to make unemployment
insurance more generous so
the u.s kind of has to be more generous
when it comes to a recession
and this is part of the debate that's in
congress right now right senators like
michael bennett want the
ui benefits to have stabilizers meaning
that as until
unemployment one proposal is until the
unemployment rate is back at
pre-pandemic levels
some stimulus will keep going out it
will gradually be tapered down
so there's a move among some democrats
in particular in congress to push
the next stimulus measure whenever that
is to include these stabilizers so it
does go out automatically
has the increased unemployment benefit
disincentivized people from going back
to work
no it hasn't there is not much work for
people to go back to
so people are getting this money not as
an alternative to actually finding work
but because so many businesses have
closed because so many businesses are
hurting
because demand is down so much this
money is going out
to make sure the entire economy doesn't
seize up and people still have money
to pay for food rent and things like
that i mean i think
i think it is true that like there are
many instances in which
generous unemployment insurance but
payments can make it less likely that
people look for work
it's not like a myth that that happens
but at the moment as john says
there's just absolutely no evidence that
it's discouraging people from working
there is this sort of doctrinal
reluctance especially among the american
right to giving people money
to giving people generous amounts of
money who are out of work because it
does in fact it can
disincentivize work but in this case
that's just that's just not true there's
no work
how will america's economic stimulus
impact inflation
so you hear this argument a lot um on
you know from certain people that
because the us is uh
is is pumping so much money into the
economy and the supply of money is
rising quickly
the inflation is definitely going to be
around the corner um
my sense is that that is not at the
moment doesn't look very likely at all
and the
the reason for that basically is that
what you're seeing at the moment is a
lot of very cautious behavior
both among firms and among households so
for instance with households
the share of income that people are
saving has gone way way up since the
pandemic began
and you're seeing the same thing with
businesses where businesses aren't
investing really
as much anywhere near as much as they
were they're conserving their money
instead so
although money's being paid out it's not
so clear that there's a lot of
there's a lot of extra money kind of
chasing goods and services which
ultimately is what
is what causes inflation to go wages
just aren't really going to be going up
that much and fundamentally to have
inflation
persistent high inflation you need to
have wages that are also going up
otherwise inflation basically sort of
runs out of steam
so at the moment i just don't see that
you know stimulus having a particularly
large impact on
inflation should americans be concerned
that the stimulus will put the
government
in debt my
my sense is um that it's it's
it's okay and legitimate to worry about
debt sustainability um there is
obviously a point
at which a country is overly indebted i
don't think the us is at that stage yet
um not least because interest rates are
very low so the share of
you know federal money that's going on
um interest repayments is quite low by
historical standards but also
i think you have to make a judgment call
as to whether
having a bit of extra or quite a lot of
extra debt is
worse than a recession
which without the government help would
have been really quite
staggeringly bad so um
i think that's the letter of two evils
really but that doesn't mean that debt
it
has no political salience i think
especially if you see
joe biden win the white house i think
there's going to be a tremendous concern
about national debt that comes from
republicans who have heretofore been
quiet both regarding the effects of
donald trump's tax cut
and the amount of money going out the
door in the stimulus politically i
expect concern
over the debt is going to rise quite
steeply if joe biden wins so john does
that mean that if we
if if biden wins that basically
unless the democrats take both houses of
congress you could basically rule out
any further fiscal stimulus
i would think so i think unless
democrats take both houses of congress
then i think you'll see a tremendous
push for austerity does that mean
that purely from an economic perspective
you you want trump to win
that is a fantastic question because if
trump wins i think never democrats and
republicans alike
democrats want to get money out the door
generally republicans will be more
willing with trump in the white house
you know if you have democratic control
of both houses of congress
and the white house i think you'll see
stimulus continue
but debt will be the issue on which
republicans go charging into the
midterms
can the positive effects of the stimulus
on the u.s economy be shown
if you look at what's happened to
household income in the u.s since the
crisis began
normally in a recession it goes down
kind of obviously because people lose
jobs and all that sort of stuff
whereas so far the this year it has gone
up which is
you know highly highly unusual so in
that very sort of simplistic sense it
has
had a positive impact on the economy
it's quite hard to
point to any obvious negative effects
that it's had
so on balance i think it's a pretty
compelling case it's done a lot of good
i think one other positive effect of
stimulus rate can be seen in
in the stabilization of poverty rates
that even as the economy contracted
and and and people lost their jobs the
poverty rate did not
measurably increase that suggests to me
that the stimulus kept people from
falling into poverty who otherwise would
have
is america becoming more socialist by
handing out the stimulus
[Music]
no i mean the workers have not
controlled the means of production
still a country of private businesses
most americans are capitalist to their
bones there's that
great john steinbeck quotes that every
poor person in america is a temporarily
embarrassed millionaire
i think that still holds true in this
case though there are a whole lot of
people who went out of work for no fault
of their own
and who need a lot of help and the
economy in general benefits from them
getting that help
so is that a socialist idea if it's a
socialist idea i guess i guess it is but
i don't think america is in
any danger of becoming a socialist
country is it possible that there is
because um the government was able to
come together
and basically spend a lot of money very
quickly
and also spending money on things that i
think in normal times would have seemed
completely outrageous
like giving people more in unemployment
they got from their job
is it possible that in the future it
sort of
opens the door towards more radical
ideas being entertained i mean
there are clearly radical ideas being
entertained that would not have been
entertained five years ago things like a
universal basic income medicare for all
those have not come about because of the
pandemic
they came about because of the
conditions that sort of prevented a
strong national response to the pandemic
so i think there is a groundswell
for those sorts of broad get money out
the door
um ideas that would have been considered
far too left
to even contemplate five or ten years
ago there is support for those
but that's distinct i think from the
response to the pandemic i think the
response to the pandemic
is is is so suey generous that it's it's
it's hard to see it laying the
groundwork
for future sort of similarly radical
ideas just because the space for that
the conditions for that would have to be
met i think the the sort of shift left
word
occurred for reasons unrelated to the
pandemic and will keep occurring for
releases unrelated to the pandemic
i'm jon fasstman the economist
washington correspondent you can stay up
to date with the issues surrounding the
pandemic and politics in america
by subscribing to our checks and balance
newsletter just click on the link
opposite
thank you for watching